and welcome to Hannity so we are at the
end of a very busy week no one's happier
by the way than President Joe Biden uh
he now gets to spend more quality time
resting and relaxing at his home in
Delaware now of course it has not been a
very busy week or month for that matter
for Joe Biden now yesterday he completed
just his fifth public event in the last
27 days according to RNC research it was
a short trip to North Carol Ina where he
attempted to talk about highspeed
internet well instead Joe got Dazed and
Confused as usual uh on stage randomly
uh starting to ask for someone named
Deborah Deborah wasn't there but he
thought he had just taken a picture with
Deborah maybe he just simply imagined it
take a look I also want to mention
Congress Deborah Ross where's
deborra the she I just had my picture
taken with her that's probably why she
left
no all kid stop anyway you oh she
couldn't be here actually that's not
true I got mixed up and she has you know
she fights very hard for the people of
this district and she's up in Washington
right now Joe is often mixed up anyway
he's not well let's just be dead honest
here this man is not well it's sad for
him it's sad that nobody in his life
will intervene it's also scary for all
of us everybody in the country
and frankly it's a scary scenario for
the world the president of the United
States of America clearly does not have
the cognitive bandwidth to do any job I
don't think he could be a Walmart
greeter for for that M for that matter
much less serve as the leader of the
Free World and he's now running for
reelection this is this is the
definition of insanity now to be fair
Biden didn't just give a speech in North
Carolina he also visited the delicious
Greensboro based chain cookout where he
enjoyed some ice cream it's Joe's big
reward for A Hard Day's Work this is
such a ridiculous game that Democrats
are now playing they trop Biden out in
front of a small crowd of hand selected
guests every few days they carefully
guide him onto the stage the fewer steps
the better somebody's on standby to walk
them off stage left or stage right they
load a short script into the
teleprompter with the biggest font
possible obviously written by a staffer
that Biden probably doesn't even know or
remember and then finally they all cross
their fingers and they're hoping and
praying and that Joe Biden can make it
through the speech without botching it
up that badly we're all supposed to what
pretend that this is normal that this is
okay that this is fine your president is
Running on Empty as a result our country
is being run into the ground by woke
entitled radical socialist who spend
their entire lives in and around the
Washington swamp and have zero
understanding of the real world you know
this is one of the major reasons why
multiple polls show Donald Trump beating
Biden in a hypothetical matchup now the
latest messenger Harris poll has Trump
up by 11 with independent voters another
major reason for Trump's polling Edge
appears to involve the many legal cases
against them Americans now rightfully
View Donald Trump is being politically
persecuted facing off against an
abusively biased system that's corrupted
by partisan bureaucrats for example fton
County DA Fanny Willis now attempting to
prosecute Trump for more than a dozen
felonies REO charges racketeering a
charge by the way normally used for
organized crime including drug dealers
and gang members and the mafia in or in
order to pull that off this aggressive
prosecution Willis used a massive amount
of taxpayer uh funding to hire outside
attorney some guy named Nathan Wade now
according to allegations from a divorce
proceeding Willis was having an affair
with this lawyer and going on trips and
tropical vacations with the lawyer uh
who was being paid an obscene amount of
money the pair were even traveling
together during their investigation into
Trump now of course this is all you know
seemingly financed by
$654,000 do that Fanny Willis alleged
boyfriend earned from the taxpayers in
fton County Georgia and to make matters
worse this guy has very limited
experience Prosecuting criminals outside
of his work with traffic citations so
you got ask what's going on here well I
think it's obvious to connect the dots
but as we speak Fanny Willis you know
beyond playing the race card is
desperately TW trying to squash this
subpoena related to this alleged
misconduct all while refusing to confirm
or deny her inappropriate Affair
allegations with a special prosecutor
that she hired and paid the obscene
amount of money to and went on vacation
with once again the very same people the
ones that Proclaim no one is above the
law they seem to think they themselves
are above the law when in reality many
of these prosecutors are nothing but
political hacks motiv motivated by Fame
and Fortune and an unyielding hatred for
all things Trump and of course they
desire power hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else